bonsoir il y a quelques années j'ai
rencontré un monsieur qui a réussi un
seulement trois minutes a multiplié par
dix
ma motivation savez ce qu'il a fait
alors je vous donne les contextes ces
messieurs était un client et j'y prenais
le travail après mon troisième congé
maternité et j'ai commencé à une mission
auprès de son entreprise avant les
déboulés début de la mission
je les rencontre est complètement au
hasard lors d'une conférence et ces
messieurs qui était le pdg d'une
multinationale
ils me voyaient pour la deuxième fois
dans sa vie et voici ce qu'il a fait
tout simplement
il m'a reconnu il est venu vers moi
il se souvenait mon prénom et il m'a
posé des questions que mon manager de la
de l'époque ne m'avait pas posée il m'a
dit tu as is
comment allez vous comment va le bébé
comment ça se passe votre reprise du
travail
est-ce que vous avez les conditions de
travail qu'il vous faut pour bien
démarrer notre mission descoings avez
vous besoin
dites le moi alors si je vous raconte
cette histoire c'est qu'elle m'a
beaucoup touché et au cours de ma vie
j'ai toujours été très intriguée par se
libère qui nous met à l'aise et qui nous
donne envie de donner le maximum
qu'est-ce qu'ils font des différents
comment je pourrais moi de venir pour me
que j'ai commencé à travailler en france
j'avais une chef
qui était extraordinaire elle était très
ouverte d'esprit ils ne s'arrêtaient pas
des préjugés
j'ai su qu'ils quand elle m'a embauché
elle avait fait contre l'avis de son
bras droit
car pour lui comme je ne venais pas des
grandes écoles
je n'avais pas les bons pedigree elle
avait aussi embauché une personne qui
était très compétente mais qui avait un
parcours qui n'était absolument pas
linéaire cette personne elle avait pris
quelques années pour s'occuper de son
enfant
puis elle avait fait des études pour
changer des carrières et elles étaient
plus âgés que les membres de l'équipe et
ma chef lui a donné sa chance en même
temps cette même chef
mais confier un mois des missions très
importantes
malgré mon jeune âge à l'époque alors
bien sûr j'ai aussi croisé des mauvais
chef de ma vie qui parmi nous n'a jamais
changé de travail à cause d'un mauvais
chef au moins ça m'est arrivé est selon
de nombreuses études dont une étude
mondiale sur le bonheur au travail
la relation la première causes
d'insatisfaction au travail et la
relation à son supérieur hiérarchique
à force d'observer autour de moi des
exemples positifs et des contre exemples
j'ai repéré trois traits qui
caractérisent ces lieder qui savent
comment attirer et comment motiver des
personnes de tous horizons
c'est à dire des personnes de tout genre
et génération avec des cultures et avec
des personnalités différentes entre
autres
ces lieder je les appelle les leaders
inclusif outre la crise des modèles
traditionnels de management et de
leadership
la raison qui m'a poussé à m'intéresser
davantage au leadership inclusif c'est
le fait que plusieurs études montrent
que des équipes diverses menées de façon
inclusive sont plus motivés plus
productive plus créative plus
performantes financièrement par exemple
selon une toute dernière et étude de
deloitte les organisations les plus
diverses et inclusive
son teint moyenne six fois à plus
innovantes
[Musique]
donc les prêts qui selon moi caractérise
les libère inclusive sont l'équité
l'empathie et la proactivité un peu
comme les trois pales d'une hélice qui
peut nous propulser très loin alors
paradoxalement la façon que j'ai trouvée
de devenir plus équitable
[Musique]
un mot la façon que j'ai trouvée les
revenus plus équitable
c'est de reconnaître le dark vador qui
est un mois autrement dit mon potentiel
à traiter les gens de façon non
équitable car les dernières recherches
en neurosciences sont catégoriques
nous avons tous des préjugés haut débit
est conscient et inconscient et en
particulier nous avons tous tendance à
favoriser les personnes qui nous
ressemblent donc que faire
entre autres je me pose de bonnes
questions
lorsque je suis en situation d eacute
man ou des promotions ou d'évaluation
des performances pour dépasser les
préjugés
je me demande toujours où est le biais
dans cette situation car toutes les
situations sont plus ou moins biaisée il
faut chercher les biais un peu comme en
chef ray charles i vous connaissez ce
petit personnage sympathique d'un livre
eu ses cages et qu'il faut trouver et
pour éviter des menteurs et des clones
je me demande toujours quelles nouvelles
perspectives
cette personne peut-elle ma portée
l'empathie c'est cette capacité qui
n'est pas naturel chez la plupart
d'entre nous et l'ins
c'est cette capacité à nous mettre à la
place de l'autre pour comprendre sa
vision du monde sont les sentiers
ce qui les motive c'est dont il a besoin
pour s'épanouir pour devenir plus
empathique
j'applique la règle des platines est-ce
qui vous connaissez la règle des
platines non connaissez peut-être la
règle d'or dans la règle d'or consiste à
traiter les gens comme nous aimerions
être prêté la règle de platine c'est une
évolution
c'est une amélioration de la règle d'or
qui consiste à traiter les autres comme
les autres et murray est retraité et non
pas comme noé meilhon est retraité et
comment j'ai fait moi pour découvrir ce
qui les gens préfèrent je suis curieuse
je m'intéresse aux gens de façon sincère
et surtout je leur pose des questions
tout à fait ce qui a fait ce qu'a fait
le monsieur qui vient contrer amont et
aubier congé maternité la pro activité
consiste à allumer les feux de
l'inclusion un nouveau les obstacles
auxquels sont confrontées les personnes
qui sont différentes de la majorité cela
peut être un entre averti dans un milieu
d'extraverti une femme dans un milieu
traditionnellement masculins une
personne d'origine étrangère
noah milieu franco français qui vous a
aidé dans votre carrière
réfléchissez et qui avez vous aider dans
votre carrière
est ce que ces personnes vous ressemble
alors les personnes qui sont différentes
de la majorité et surtout différent de
la majorité qui a du pouvoir au sein des
organisations
c'est personnellement que souvent dans
leurs réseaux des mentors et des
sponsors influents
et c'est pour ça que l'une des façons
que j'ai trouvé de devenir plus
proactive c'est d'être le mentor des
personnes qui sont quelque part
différente de moi est différente de la
majorité
est ce que j'arrive moi être toujours in
lieder inclusive
bien sûr que non et curieusement c'est
parce que je sais que je suis
perfectible que je peux continuer
d'aimer aime être suffisamment une
question pour désigner une l'idée
inclusive le leadership inclusive est
une pratique qui demande beaucoup
d'humilité
ce n'est pas une destination
c'est un chemin comprend pour aller loin
professionnellement et pour faire de
belles rencontres
je vous souhaite un excellent voyage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]